hey man what's up kid
nothing much oh this is a beautiful
thing
mr. ever come back this is beautiful man
I never would have seen this coming
it's happening that's how we do man tell
me about the businessman his t-shirts
your main biz so I'm a graphic designer
in the illustrator I just recently got
fired from my last I'm Marissa
I'm originally from Alabama I've been
living in Houston Texas for three years
and like the intention was to uh to do
the art a full time but I graduated from
college in 2013 couldn't get a job and
so I had to keep working different odd
jobs around Houston and then like the
whole goal was like I want to do art
full-time okay it's at the surviving
past natural disaster other stuff
anyways we here now where I'm trying to
get packed I'm trying to really increase
my revenue so I can touch more alive
gotta lost a car and all the other kind
of stuff for you as you say you'll be
there know money is important but it's
not the main thing so I'm just
constantly trying to just be focused on
my why like what gets me up out the bed
at five and six o'clock in the morning
every day when I obviously could be
sleeping and it's like I got that you
know I want to do this I want to impact
other artists I'm constantly on here
giving away a lot of free game cuz you
know some people are intimidated can
they believe that oh you know I tell you
you know how my business work or
whatever you got to take me out to
gaming well that works in my mind like
you you got to be a loser
you think that way because you know
everybody has some value and it's like I
know that the value I put in the world
it won't be replaced when I die so
that's how that design there you're
gonna you're gonna sell that what's the
plane man yeah yeah that's that's the
point I just really did like a crash
course this past weekend really trying
to make myself learn illustrator I'm
really fluent in Photoshop there's still
a lot more things that I want to learn
but okay I made myself learn how to
create logo this weekend I finally came
out I really spent like the last two
months trying to figure out branding so
I figure out my brand colors know you
know all that other little technical
stuff and now since we got ahead
together I just got like a bunch of
merchandise idea I'm sitting off over
five years and
finally have the skills to implement
this I'm really happy about that and
that's my girl making all kinds of
merchandise we're gonna put that up
what's your platform WWF ain't calm sy
RUP
i NK calm but but there's that like t
spring or like who's making them for you
I'm using príncipe and print book okay I
don't know this guy's cool man when you
lunch him is it up already I already got
a website ready to go by only have just
one print I was seven and I've already
uploaded like two other designs but it's
like they're hidden and I want to make
sure like I have this full of bang ready
to go for tomorrow so that's why I'm
working on the night so nothing's on the
website yet there's one thing on the
website that's this print I was selling
and like it hasn't even been promoting
it so that's my fault because I'm more
focused on trying to get these shirt
designs together syrup ink.com I'm right
I'm checking you out see we've got here
invest in your dreams I like it okay
where's the t-shirt chopped all products
this is it
so yes I'm selling it right now yeah
everything else is hidden that's a
t-shirt right is that a teacher no no
that's just a print I was gonna turn
that into a shirt but I want to see how
that my uh my people are gonna respond
to do they want that as a shirt do they
want as a print I put that up in like
you know I'm having traffic come through
and people are by like you know other
old designs if I took them off and now
if I I'm trying to upload with all this
new stuff what's the thing on your page
right now what is that a monkey what is
that a happy face what am I looking at
so a system the name of my company is
called serve sandwich studios y'all
wanted my icon to be like a piece of
toast so that's all I see I got it okay
okay that's cool man that's cool so
that's gonna be the t-shirt toast yes
let's see here's our designs what else
you got this is the back of the shirt
called fear kills dreams this is the
back and then this is the front is there
anything I can help you with while my
main concern as of late is just like how
to generate consistent cash flow as a
creative person that's one of the main
hold us by I don't try to focus on that
a whole lot I'm not sure but it's like I
know that's not number one so I'm just
really been focusing on providing value
and giving away a lot of information
well I really need how to generate more
income like you want to be somebody's
outsourced design firm or you want to
sell your own creations or what do you
want to try to do I'm leaning more so
towards a set of my own creations but
it's like I came up with a 20-year plan
not too long ago is like later on down
the line
I want to have like two different
graphic design firms between Houston and
Alabama and it's with like a couple
spots around the world all right but
like you know 20 years man who knows
we're gonna be in 20 years right right
right
like let's focus on the next two months
the thing with where you're going is
like that those designs can fly but you
have to build the community to sell them
right people don't know what that icon
is it doesn't mean anything to them yet
so you got to do the work to build a
brand so that people actually want that
toast they don't know what it is so the
back sound the back looks cool but
people don't know what it is yet because
you're trying to build a personal you're
trying to build a brand but it takes a
while to get that stuff going right it's
it's like creating regular contents of
the the logo means something right that
t-shirt could sell on its own if you
make it the front I don't know how much
how obsessed you are about like building
a brand at this point versus just
starting to build some traction and
starting to make some revenue like if
you had some sick designs that could
sell but they may not want it with the
thing on the front yet right so I don't
know how important that is to you I mean
the original I am one of my cousin that
was head that was helping me that that's
been support me since I've been out here
he has suggested you know putting that
on the back and putting the fear kills
dreams on the back and didn't have my
logo on the front so the original idea
was to have that on the back I was to
have fear kills dreams on the front and
then it's like before you came in a
couple of people that have supported me
because a few years I've been on here in
Houston I was asking them for their
opinion so that was another reason why
this randomly decided to go live and I
mentioned a couple people that support
me like you know what do y'all think
about these are
design should this be on the front
should this be on the back and I'm just
all with the people that were saying but
I completely understand what you're
saying if I like you know why should
people care about us my love he's a
piece of toast some people think it's a
but yeah one of my friends started with
Mickey Mouse and that's hilarious
what wait what did I call it what did I
call it
Oh monkey a monkey yeah okay okay I you
know what it looks more like a piece of
toast in a monkey listen dude I mean you
could do both right like the beauty of
our line is you're not actually buying
ten thousand t-shirts that end up
sitting in your your basement you know
like you could do both you could launch
that one with the thing on the front but
the toast the the toast like there's a
toast guy have a name you building a
whole thing around him yes I come I'm
influenced real hard about this the guy
from Italy named he had his company's
tokidoki and I also love Johnny Cupcakes
so like the thing I love about tokidoki
is like there's like a whole line of
characters following me so the name of
this candy is called toasty and I always
another toasty toasty toasty okay okay I
like that toasty so so do both like have
your shop and have that on the front and
the thing on the back that the fear
kills dreams and then flip it and have
it on the front too and then sell both
and see what flies I don't know enough
about the platform that I figured which
one you're on like how much of a
marketplace they have so if you get any
kind of awareness you can put any tags
on to see if you know that's something
anybody would be interested in and then
if I'm you I try to find influencers who
care about who have your audience and
like send them a shirt you know like
print off 20 shirts find 20 influencers
who you love who might promote it for
you like wear it in an IG post or a
story and then see which one they want
and if they're helping promote you you
start getting some sales how quickly can
you ram out the youth full of ideas I
can you can you jam out these these
t-shirts pretty quick or that you're
still learning that the tools and the
gear and everything now I'm making them
pretty quick like really these all these
shirts out I'll show
Jews not too long ago just the black and
white no those although I did yesterday
but the rest of my to do that tonight
and feel like I'm also working on
another one called big girls only uh-huh
okay that's cool I'm starting to flesh
out ideas from like five years ago so
now since like I have at least the
elementary understanding of Illustrator
I know like which designer would look
better with the cleaner look of
Illustrator they're like if I did it in
Photoshop so now it's like I'm just
really cranking out ideas just to see
any like what uh people gravitate
towards that's my gameplay as of now
yeah so like you take something like
that like big girls only arrows the
first one fear kills dreams was that the
quote looking at like who's using that
in hashtags like go to Instagram look
for the hashtag big girls only and look
for the hashtag for your kills dreams
and see if there's anybody who's posted
to either those hashtags that have has a
sizable account and then show them the
graphic and say hey I'm making this into
t-shirt thank you thank you thank maybe
they look at it they say this is sick
this is awesome like how do I get one
I'd love to talk about it I may be the
look on his haters though the ugliest
thing I've ever seen in my life like
awesome either way man either way is
good but but if you especially if you're
taking like tiny little phrases like
that people are using those in hashtags
and so you already get a set like
somebody who's made a post about big
girls only they're they care about the
cost right like they posted something
that I mean that means something to them
like that doesn't mean anything to me
right like I've never posted anything
love big girls only on my account so you
don't want me wearing that t-shirt it
won't help you with anything because
that's not my audience but they're
people who have used that tag and it's
like yeah they love it and they'll see
your t-shirt and say ho this is awesome
right like somebody who gets to my
vision too
and and when they get it in the mail
they'll freak out and they they can't
wait to show their audience now if it's
somebody who has like 45 followers it
may not be worth your time to do it but
if they're bigger I don't know what the
threshold would be for you I'd probably
be looking at like at least in the five
digits maybe six digits right
account how much would it cost you to
send them a t-shirt really less than $20
right around $20 cuz you got to order it
yourself right and then you have to ship
it out to them or I guess you can have
it shipped right to them from the
supplier right that's correct
but you get to have a cheaper price and
what people buy it for from the site yes
so like if it cost you 20 bucks and then
how much do you make if somebody buys
one of your t-shirts yeah yeah like four
or five dollars yeah okay so so if it's
five bucks in the cost of 20 then every
t-shirt you get out you have to be able
to sell you know at least four to five
t-shirts to break even they're gonna
post it are you gonna get four to five
sales from that you know you may get it
from one you may not get it from another
one but if you test it with ten twenty
influencers you know it's gonna cost you
200 bucks or ten I test it out like so
you find the people who love that
message they love it they're hash
tagging it up they've got a sizable
following you you DM them and say hey
I'm making this t-shirt like make a
video I'd make a video like show them
the show them the graphic hey I love
what you're talking about with big girls
only I made a t-shirt around it I don't
know if you're interested I'd love to
send you one because you know whatever
the reason why you picked that mm-hm I
didn't see what they say and if they're
like yeah I'd love to wear that and show
it on my IG then you spend the 20 bucks
and you send it out I also draw
portraits a little quick blush shock
rush out here shot portrait and I'll
reap that for a couple of people I yo I
just you know I've been one of those are
if I draw you and like I've drawn abjure
just random people on Instagram and sent
and shipped them a physical copy and
I've signed so that that is definitely
work and I guess I've had to apply that
same formula with your shirt yeah and
like this is where it's not just your
audience because you have a hard court
like when I joined your thing you had
four or five people on or something you
know you've got your hardcore audience
but it's gonna be hard to make money off
of the audience right now right
so that's figuring out who are them
brand new people that I can reach out to
that might buy this thing and so you
could rapidly you could rapidly
test that right like you take big girls
only you look at the hashtag you find 25
influencers you reach out to them if
everybody loves it great you test it out
if everybody hates it okay you design
sucks like move on to something else
awesome right right right
and take the same thing with the fears
kill dreams like hashtag fear kills
dreams awesome see what's there do the
same thing and so you're not actually
you're spending time to make the designs
and to and to find the people and reach
out and do the ends but you're not
spending any cost in making anything
until you actually have some interest
and then what you can do like if fears
kill dreams one is popping and all these
influencers want to wear it then you
could put that on your website right and
you can show all the influencers wearing
the shirt rockin it for you you got like
you got free models rockin your shirt
who have some brand name recognition I
mean you're not gonna get Kim Kardashian
to wear your t-shirt but you can get
people lower down the wrong and then you
throw that up on your big girls only or
your fear kills dreams landing page on
your website with all these people who
have worn your shirt you start building
a little movement around it like you
already have your t-shirt that's what
I'd be spending my time on take both of
those and spend the next hour doing that
find 25 people make a video DM for each
of them you know take you 10 seconds per
video DM and then see this interest and
if somebody says yeah I'd wear that cool
print it off and send it to them and see
what happens maybe if I'm you I probably
do like the front and then put the
little put the little toast on the front
but at the bottom somewhere I think that
would sell better than than having the
logo on the front and the thing on the
back but but test it maybe maybe they're
like no I love that toast like man I see
that tell us tonight I'm just I get
happen just like that toast man I want
to see that every day when I wake up you
know I don't know like you see but I
would I would design the style where you
put the thing on the front the quote in
the front and they're like the little
toast I got the bottom left or bottom
right you know I don't tell you how to
do your art but just as a sample as a
test and then I'd spend the next two
hours reaching out
to influencers for both of those
keywords hashtags and see if you get
interest and if nobody likes it then
maybe you drop that t-shirt move on to
something else the great thing for you
is you got a ton of ideas you got ideas
for days and you have the skill to
actually turn it into something right
you can design it what a lot of people
have the ideas but they don't have the
skill to actually do it you're lucky
you're you're fortunate it's awesome now
rapid prototype get it out there to
people who can help you promote it and
see what they say like if you made a
shirt around believe something I want to
see it right like you should DM me and
say Evan hey man I'm a fan of your work
I made a shirt around believe what do
you think if you like it I love to send
you a sample right I'm gonna look at and
say man that piece of toast is sick I
will love it give me give me my believe
t-shirt right it's gonna come and then
I'm gonna wear it you're gonna hold it
up or wear it or whatever if I like it
right if the design sucks forget it but
if I like it right I'll say yes and I
wore people send me stuff all the time
and and I put it up when I like it but
you can ask them if they like it before
you end up sending anything out so
that's what I spend my next two hours
doing those two t-shirts reach out to 25
people and every day like until you
start getting some traction on one of
your designs every day new design once a
day 25 new people once a day until you
get enough people saying yeah man I want
that shirt and then you're working about
creating the landing page you don't need
to worry about the website on the
t-shirt that nobody's interested in
right so I get some interest from the
people who might be able to help promote
it for you and then if they like it
they're wearing it then it's okay it's
worth spending a little more time making
the website landing page getting some
interest drawn up for it thank you
also if you want to know what I think
and what other successful entrepreneurs
think about building confidence check
out my new to 54 confidence series where
every day for the next 254 days for free
I will send you a 30 second to five
minute video in the morning to help you
build unstoppable confidence
the link is in the description below if
you want to be more confident you need
to surround yourself with things that
make you feel confident realizing that
any big endeavor is the collection of a
lot of small steps that came before if
you're doing work that you love you're
more likely to follow through you're
more likely to do it because it doesn't
feel like work because you love doing it
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that not one drop of
myself work depends on your it's
something serene if you liked this video
and you want to learn the fastest way to
grow a channel check out the video right
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there first off it's never as quick as
you think it'll be just in general
things always take longer